do you got do you women but do do you
women believe in gender roles
like rose for the man and rose for the
woman i think it's only going to work if
in that in that instance where the man
is actually providing
and
then i will i don't i wouldn't mind if
the guy is doing his part but if we're
splitting why would i be taking the load
of everything so i'm doing the same
things that you're doing plus more
and we will you know
when i finish that finish that's what is
going on i think you guys are missing
the point where i'm saying if the person
is not
doing if the guy is not providing
if the guy's not providing
why am i going to do the extra mile oh
no no no no no no
i am 100 for
for the woman or whoever like if if i'm
going to take the lesser half or you
know you're going to
if if the guy is providing that is more
that is more because money it's not
trust me it's not like in the sense of
this as marriage goes right now marriage
is the perfect combination it's equal
right it takes balance so my thing is if
you're
if your money
because you're both going to pay at the
end of the day one is paying in money
and one is paying in time in that sense
because the roles that the woman are
doing
you're not getting money for it but
it has to be done like you're paying in
your time so my thing is we both have to
be paying equally in that sense like who
is the balance who are the highest um
consumer spenders
women right so that means you do have
you do get paid for it like a man is not
gonna come back from work yeah
um
while his woman is in his house and not
look after his woman that doesn't sound
like that a traditional relationship
that's not our traditional relationship
yeah but i was having this conversation
the other day i was saying this this
generation
are not marriage material yeah they're
not i really felt both the men and the
women they're not marriage materials so
people are talking about people are
talking about relation they're talking
about marriage nowadays and i'm like you
guys are joking with yourselves because
you guys know that you ain't marriage
material and the girls know that
marriage material so what's everyone
talking about yeah i feel like nowadays
it's kind of like
all right so when you meet a girl
one of the questions that they're gonna
ask you is what's your body count and
it's not like
well it's more like between guys as well
i'll ask you that
sorry guys yes he has
sad yeah is that an age thing though
yeah yeah yeah i think that's it
like i was trying to say like
the reason why we're not like the lower
generations already marriage material is
because we've really seen like a shift
between like what role models are like
nowadays like sex is more like
celebrated but it's like overly
celebrated to where like now
everything's just about sex
like there's no intimacy
and the people that are doing it are
fully involved in full relationships
like beyonce sung single lady she's
married
i don't cook i don't clean this car
she's she cooking and cleaning she's
married do you know what i mean it's
like the people the same people that
tell you don't
this you know i'm saying city girls is
the same one that you know i'm saying
she's got her man
she's sorted she's normally got like
money in her bank account anyway the
person that says that because if she
didn't she wouldn't say that because she
would rely on someone to help her out
like it's like girls that say i'm an
independent lady but you got a man that
takes you shopping you got a man that
buys you bags you got a man that does
this you got amanda you know what i'm
saying sleeps with you when you want you
got a man that does that's not
independent lady that's like you know
i'm just hey that's it's different
yeah and like with that like when we
talk about like independent women in a
relationship
i'm just i'm still gonna be buying her
stuff it's not like i'm gonna be like
i'm gonna come home and be like you got
your own money like go to the store buy
yourself like everything you want
like at the end of the day it's like
even like if you listen to like
something like what they preach they're
always talking about some
uh
this where as percy you're gonna make
him do this that the third but it's
never
i'm gonna go to work get my money up and
then go buy a chain
or you talk about men saying that like
woman okay they never say like like when
they're telling like what they
i can't
it's kind of like telling the younger
generation
to like use their body
to like control men
but it's not like they're not telling
them to use their body to like go to
work
i get what you're saying yeah
so like it's more on a gender though i
don't feel like that i just think that's
what sells i don't think
i don't know i don't think it's a choice
like music used to be so different do
you know what i mean well you think it's
a music's probably it's a music it's not
a music problem but music heavily
influences the younger generation like
massively so girls seeing about twerking
their ass and getting birkins and stuff
of course the younger generation gonna
be like that's what we need to do
so but the thing is but when it comes on
you listen to it
um yeah
we'll be the first shaker house to do
that but i'm saying like there's not
really isn't that a whole contradiction
yeah
isn't that like a whole contradiction no
i'm just saying these tell them to not
do what they're talking about no but
then
but you're now promoting what the song's
doing by shaking your ass to it no but
also like you have to think about you
can listen to the song but not do it but
if you're listening to it in a public
area you're spreading that message like
now people are listening to that song
like oh so that's what we need to do
let's get on that
i'm so i can land my point i'm just
saying words carry a lot too and if
you're repeating things like whereas
[ __ ] all the time or twerk twerk twerk
or whatev whatever it is you keep say
that sing that in a club you're thinking
that or then conditioning yourself but
it's come on and you've danced to it
right yeah i mean i'm a dancer so of
course like is it is a different like i
tune a different energy whenever i'm
dancing to anything but again it's it's
not funny
where do the contradictions stop and a
double standard stop like
because we're talking about like
because
a lot of men have seen
the kind of contradictions that women go
that women have right and the kind of
double standards that they have and so
i think a lot of the reason why men of
this day and age are angry is because
they're seeing these double standards
they're seeing these contradictions and
they're just expected to just take them
it's like we're just supposed to take it
we're not supposed to question it we're
supposed to take it women can basically
do what they want right and we've just
gotta be like all right fine yeah it's
like cold dance in this female
calisthenics do you know what i mean
like
it's another listen never to believe
hold on to the sport now like you don't
mean like it's like come on you're
allowed to be multifaceted like you're
allowed like for me i can appreciate or
understand a song is sexual and not and
dance to it sexually
but also there's another side of me like
i'm not just that one
twerk in a club like i can then also
listen to [ __ ] gospel on a sunday and
smoking awful and all that there's other
side we're multifaceted we're not just
one thing but don't you think women are
generally seen a certain way and
they're not allowed to break that facade
of who they are like because if the
facade of what a woman is is broken then
women get pissed off like for instance i
was
the johnny dep and amber heard case
right
so amber had came out saying that john
when she initially came out she said
johnny depp was the abuser and she was
believed instantly right because women
are obviously
you might want to turn it off bro
the police um
yeah yeah because women are instantly
seen as the victim
the entity is a victim and so as it
comes out
you come to find that
she's been lying she's been saying
certain things you know certain things
aren't true
like
how is it that women tend in this dance
society in this day and age to be like
i'm a strong independent woman
i am the boss but then you can switch
and instead be like oh my god i'm just
an innocent little person
i feel like maybe that's because like
they can do that but then they still
have men to fall back to you like what
do you mean like okay so they can be a
strong independent woman but when that
doesn't work out there's always going to
be someone ready
to like give her everything